Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this is going
to be my Mockingjay Review.
Hopefully you’ve had a chance to see it.
Just in case I’m going to do a non-spoilery
part first and then I’ll get into favorite
moments with specific stuff.
I’m not quite as connected to the Hunger
Games books as much as Song of Ice and Fire,
I only read the first one.
So when I saw Catching Fire and now this one
I didn’t know what was going to happen.
You can feel this giant shift in the tone
of the franchise within the first fifteen
minutes of the movie.
The first two films were all about this big
epic event.
The Games.
And now that the line has been drawn in the
sand between these two big powers inside Panem
it’s much more about the power of propaganda.
Propaganda was a big part of the first two
movies, like when they made the tributes go
on Ceasar’s show.
It was very clear that all that was bullshit
and all the characters trying to survive it.
Now Propaganda is the Games.
Or you could say it’s taken the role the
Games played in the story.
A big call to action to the masses of Panem.
It’s just that now we get to hear the other
side’s story.
And they do have a lot of fun telling that
story inside the movie.
The circumstances are super depressing and
Katniss as a character is still very much
a reluctant non-traditional hero.
But they’re still able to get some good
laughs in.
It’s even funnier when you listen to what
the actors say about pranks they played on
each other while they were filming.
Liam Hemsworth said that anytime he’s ever
had a kissing scene with Jennifer Lawrence,
just to be funny she’s always eaten a ton
of garlic or something really gross right
before they do it.
Elizabeth Banks as Effie also brings a lot
of humor to the story.
Of all the films so far I enjoyed her the
most in Mockingjay.
She’s always been the Clown but now she’s
like the Sad Clown, which for some reason
seems funnier to me.
I was never a giant fan of Woody Harrelson’s
Haymitch.
In real life he does share a lot of Haymitch’s
qualities but I always felt like he was miscast
for the role.
He has this strange acting style that feels
like it just doesn’t fit with a really serious
genre film like this.
I think he works better when he’s allowed
to be super crazy, like in Zombieland.
The Hunger Games movies feel like they take
themselves really seriously, which I don’t
mind, but Mockingjay is by far the most serious
of them all, and Haymitch doesn’t feel like
he belongs.
Julianne Moore and Philip Seymour Hoffman
were great together.
They’re both amazing character actors so
you instantly forget it’s them.
It’s always fun to watch actors disappear
into their characters.
They made it a big point to state that they
didn’t use any CG to complete Hoffman’s
scenes.
He died before he’d finished his last few
scenes and they chose to just give those lines
to another character.
It’s not something you notice but the producers
made a big deal about explaining what they
did.
Just to address some of the criticism of breaking
the movie into two parts.
I think the funniest comment I saw on twitter
was Duncan Jones, the director who’s doing
Warcraft right now.
He said something like “The Only reason
to break the third movie in a trilogy into
two parts, is because you want to buy a big
ass yacht.”
I kind of agree, Mockingjay was written as
one book just like the other two.
If they could do the other two books in a
single film.
They could have done Mockingjay in one film
too.
If you really hate that people are doing this
with franchise movies now, you can blame Harry
Potter and Warner Brothers.
They’re the first big franchise to do the
two part finale.
Warner Brothers also did it again with the
Third Hobbit Movie.
The Hobbit was originally going to be directed
by Guillermo Del Toro and be just one film.
But then Warner Brothers turned it into two
films, added a bunch of made up things that
weren’t in the book.
Then added a third film with even more made
up stuff.
And now studios can suddenly turn a 500 million
dollar profit into 2 or 3 billion dollars
over a 10 year period.
So this trend isn’t going away anytime soon.
Disney is doing it with the Marvel films now.
Avengers 3 is going to be broken into two
films.
Let’s all be honest though, we’ll still
spend the money to go see everything.
I’m just as big a part of the problem as
the studios because I support them financially.
Whatever.
Mockingjay is still a really fun ride, if
you haven’t read the books there are some
great big set pieces that will freak you out
in a really awesome way.
The ending was a nice WTF.
And if you have read the book you’ll still
be crying your eyes out the whole time.
If you haven’t seen it yet it’s totally
worth the money to see it in a theater.
Here’s my big question for you guys, what
was your favorite moment and do you care that
they broke it into two parts to make more
money?
Now it’s time to get into spoilers, I’m
going to do my Top 5 moments so careful if
you haven’t seen it.
Here we go.
Number 5 - President Snow Facts
Like I said, I hadn’t read the Catching
Fire or Mockingjay books, so there was a lot
I learned about President Snow when Finnick
went on the air.
When they were jamming the airwaves with spam.
They were spamming as a way to attack the
Capitol's defenses.
Which was also a pretty cool trick.
Remember how I said propaganda was the core
of the film this time around.
The propaganda are the games now and there
are only two participants in the ring.
Finnick explained that he survived inside
the capitol by trading secrets, so it was
fun to listen to him spill his guts about
how President Snow rose to power.
Like the fact that he uses the white roses
to cover the smell of blood in his mouth from
wounds that will never heal.
Number 4 - Katniss In The Studio
The first time they try to make some fake
propaganda was like the first time the movie
let itself have fun.
The whole beginning is so depressing and serious.
All the Hunger Games movies in general begin
with the absence of action and even sound.
It’s one of the defining characteristics
of the franchise in that they begin on such
downer moments.
So watching Katniss try to act was pretty
funny.
And it brought Haymitch back into the story.
Even though he felt very out of place in district
13.
Number 3 - Jennifer Lawrence Singing The Hanging
Tree Song
I don’t think I’ve ever heard her sing
in any of her movies but I thought it was
beautifully melancholic.
You’re happy and sad at the same time.
The song is very appropriate to the story
of the movie, but just in general it was a
great performance.
Number 2 - Effie Trinket Hates District 13
Elizabeth Banks was so much more fun this
time around.
Sad Clown Effie Trinket has all this wit and
style and no one in District 13 gives a shit.
I was never a huge fan of fancy Effie during
the first two films, but she’s like the
pressure release valve for seriousness.
Effie For the Win.
Number 1 - Peeta Is Completely Nanners
Because I went into this not knowing the story
I thought President Snow was either going
to turn Peeta into one of those genetically
altered dogs like in Catching Fire.
I just remember that in one of the other books
the dead tributes get their DNA spliced with
big freak attack dogs.
I thought that was what they were going to
find when they were traveling through the
Tribute Center.
The way they edited that whole sequence teased
a major reveal, so I was kind of dissapointed
when they just cut away.
It felt like it was building to something
else than them just being cut off from communications.
The actual reveal, that Peeta was cranked
up on Tracker Jacker venom was a great ending
though.
Right now I’m trying to finish a couple
of videos before Walking Dead tomorrow.
I’ll post my Korra Q&A next and then I’ll
try to get Constantine out.
If I run out of time I’ll just get that
out Monday.
I did see Big Hero 6 and Interstellar but
didn’t have time to do videos for them.
Since TV is going on break in the next couple
of weeks I’ll have a little more time for
Hobbit whatnot and some Star Wars Episode
7 too.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything
and please leave movie video requests in the
comment.
In case you haven’t seen me mention before,
Youtube gave me a new beta feature to play
with.
If you’re watching on your mobile phone
or your ipad you can click up here for extra
links.
It’s the same as the links I add over here.
They’re the same.
Right now click here to catch up on Legend
of Korra and Click here to learn about the
new Game Of Thrones video game.
Thanks for watching, I’ll see you guys tonight.
High Fives!